because today we're talking about how JK
merch is crushing it hey hey hey thank
you guys you seriously but also what is
some dope JK merch that we can use to BU
our audience to make
profit well it's disgusting whenever you
want profit it's bad some of the fans
have like the best ideas what are some
of them um one of them is Anthony
dancing and saying did it didn't happen
nor I mean what what you referring to
yeah which fan said that what's the
context of that bunny walking said Uncle
chin shirt is fire but also need a Steve
shirt saying Anthony Lee had a dance
about how 9/11's not real that's a good
one Steve saying yeah that's really good
Anthony and Bin Laden back to back in a
b boy stance the squad Bin Laden that be
tight you guys do you realize that that
means it did happen tell the about the
details you can't explain art what about
another shirt it's like Hurricane
Katrina then you have Anthony going like
I don't even see
it he goes what hurricane